now data structures and graph Theory
a data structure is
Analogous to a mathematical structure, right?
We said it's a thing that contains elements and
programming we have similar.
Ideas, but we call them data structures. They are mathematical structures
that contain data.
as elements
in programming we could have an array.
or
a group there are something called a graph or
it could be a binary tree.
Now if you are a programmer.
Or if you're someone who is just learning programming.
then
the first thing that you will encounter is a linear
data structure something like an array.
And python is they're called lists.
now
Sets as well, that's two poles.
These are linear data structures.
and these are
obviously they have very
wide applications, but they are not the
right data structure in every scenario.
more useful a more useful type of data structure or a
more useful
category of the structure
Is the nonlinear data structure or we can
call them graphs. These are widely used
and social media applications and databases.
in The Internet of Things
They're quite powerful.
but they can
they get they can be quite complicated.
and
some of these
will require
mathematical literacy
at the very least you should be able to understand what?
Some concepts are in graph Theory. You need
to know what is a for example a graph a multi
graph a path.
the different types of
the different names we give to graphs.
Because these are they have names and these
names will be referenced in
order to explain an idea.
And if you want to know what the explanation is,
well, you will come across some mathematical expression.
So we might once again.
to become a very
You know Advanced or Elite.
software programmer programmer
or data engineer
or if you're in the world of Finance, you want to write algorithms
for financial or algorithmic Trading?
then
you will invariably come across.
Graph-based data structures and if you want to understand
them and Implement them on your own.
You'll have to have the mathematical.
Foundation
but let me at least give you a high level illustration.
Before we turn to the tutorial and we can talk about the
mathematical.
syntax